digamos que tenemos un ángulo theta aquí
tenemos un ángulo theta y lo estoy
dibujando sobre el círculo unitario con
la convención usual de que el rayo
inicial del ángulo es la parte positiva
del eje x mientras que el punto de
intersección del radio final con el
círculo unitario determinan coseno de
teta y seno de teta así es que el coseno
dt está el coseno de teta dejan usar un
color que resalte aquí el coseno de teta
es la coordenada en x del punto donde el
rayo final intersecta el círculo
unitario podemos considerar entonces que
el coseno de teta es la longitud de este
segmento que estoy dibujando en color
púrpura la longitud de este segmento que
tenemos aquí corresponde entonces a
coseno de teta mientras que la
coordenada en ye del punto de
intersección es el seno de theta lo cual
corresponde a la longitud de esta línea
que tenemos aquí la distancia del punto
al eje x corresponde a la coordenada n
es decir la longitud correspondiente a
este segmento es
no detecta y esto hace sentido nos
muestra la correspondencia del círculo
unitario con la definición de shock
actual recuerda soca todas vamos a
escribirlo acá
tohá
esto sólo es seno el seno del ángulo el
seno de teta es igual al cateto opuesto
seno de teta es igual al cateto puesto
que en este caso mide seno de teta es
igual al cateto opuesto que es seno de
teta entre la hipotenusa pero la
hipotenusa vale 1 pues es el radio del
círculo unitario
así es que seno ett es igual a 0 etc
otra manera de ver esto es que el seno
de teta es igual al cateto opuesto entre
la hipotenusa el cateto opuesto dividido
entre la hipotenusa que es 1 el cateto
opuesto dividido entre 1 es cateto
opuesto con lo cual el cateto opuesto es
igual al seno de teta o el seno de teta
es igual al cateto opuesto lo mismo
aplica para coseno coseno
de teta es igual adyacente es igual al
cateto adyacente sobre hipotenusa y dado
que la hipotenusa vale 1 esto es igual
al cateto adyacente el coseno de teta es
la longitud del cateto adyacente esto no
es más que un repaso verificando que la
definición de soca tohá corresponde a la
definición del círculo unitario hagamos
algo interesante
este es el ángulo theta ahora
consideramos el ángulo theta más pi
sobre dos tetas y sobre dos si voy a
sumarle pi sobre dos a este ángulo voy a
obtener un rayo que es perpendicular al
primero al sumar ti sobre dos y cuando
digo pi sobre dos se entiende que son pi
sobre dos radiales y pi sobre dos
radiales ya sabemos que equivale a 90
grados
así es que básicamente estamos agregando
un ángulo de 90 grados así es que este
ángulo este ángulo que tenemos aquí este
está más y sobre 2 ahora lo que quiero
hacer aquí y creo que es la parte más
interesante de este vídeo
podemos relacionar seno de teta más y
sobre 2 ya sea con el seno de teta o con
el coseno de teta te invito a que le
pongas pausa el vídeo y trates de hacer
esto por tu cuenta antes de que lo
hagamos juntos bien el seno de teta más
y sobre 2 es a partir de la definición
del círculo unitario la coordenada en y
de este punto esto de aquí esta longitud
que tenemos aquí déjame marcarla esta
longitud que tenemos aquí esta longitud
corresponde al seno de teta más pi sobre
dos seno de teta más y sobre dos ahí lo
tenemos cómo se relaciona esto con lo
que obtuvimos aquí previamente al ver la
gráfica parece que agarramos este
triángulo y lo rotamos 90 grados 90
grados que es de hecho lo que hicimos
tomamos este lado terminal y le sumamos
90 grados o pi sobre dos radiales
y si queremos ser más rigurosos con esto
todo este ángulo que marcamos con blanco
aquí me de teta más y sobre 2 como la
parte que abarca el primer cuadrante
mide y sobre 2 entonces este ángulo de
aquí me de teta ahora considerando esto
que tenemos aquí si tratamos de
relacionar este lado que pinte aquí en
magenta con este ángulo teta en amarillo
de acuerdo a la definición de shock
actúa aquí con respecto a teta
este es el cateto adyacente consideremos
esto con más detalle cómo podemos
relacionar el cateto al día sentí la
hipotenusa y aquí por supuesto la
hipotenusa vale 1 pues estamos en el
círculo unitario coseno nos relaciona
adyacente hipotenusa tenemos entonces
que el coseno de este ángulo teta coseno
de teta es igual al cateto adyacente que
ya vimos que es el seno de teta más lo
voy a mover un poco para abajo
esto es igual al seno de teta más y
sobre 2 sobre la hipotenusa que mide 1
sobre 1 lo cual es igual simplemente a
seno de teta más y sobre 2 estupendo
hemos obtenido una sorprendente relación
entre coseno y seno coseno de teta es
igual al seno de teta más pi sobre 2 o
también podríamos establecer la como
seno de teta más y sobre 2 es igual a
jose no detecta te invito que al
terminar este vídeo intentes obtener
otras relaciones con que se relaciona
por ejemplo seno de teta o con que se
relaciona con seno de teta más y sobre 2
te invito a que intentes obtener otras
relaciones por tu cuenta